le sidaction a donc démarré aujourd'hui
pendant tout le week-end toutes les
chaînes dont celles du groupe france
télévisions se mobilisent pour vous
informer sur la maladie
vous pouvez adresser vos dons en
composant le 110 et cela jusqu'au 19
avril
on dénombre toujours 40 millions de
personnes dans le monde qui vivent avec
le virus du sida dont 150 mille en
france
le combat doit donc continuer mais
l'espoir existe aussi grâce à la
découverte de nouvelles molécules
exemple avec ce reportage de jean daniel
flaysakier et lionel langlade lotfi à 61
ans il est marié père de famille est
depuis 17 ans il héberge un hôte dont il
se serait bien passé le virus vih un
virus devenu avec le temps résistant à
tous les médicaments existants il y a un
an
lotfi n'avait vraiment plus qu'une seule
volonté un jour je dois mourir là soit
les choses que demander à la nuit en
dormant
mais le puits est toujours là et bien il
le doit en grande partie à un médicament
un produit pas encore commercialisé mais
qu'il reçoit depuis un an
le médicament c'est celui ci c'est ce
que l'on appelle une anti intégral et
voici comment il fonctionne
le virus vih ce sir des cellules de
défense et lymphocytes pour se
reproduire son programme génétique la rn
virale se transforme en adn et va
s'insérer dans le programme de la
cellule le virus pourra ainsi être
reproduits jusqu'à 1 milliard
d'exemplaires par jour
l'anti intégral va bloquer
l'incorporation du message du virus plus
de reproduction le virus devient
indécelable dans le sang du patient et
pour l'eau-de-vie l'amélioration s'est
vu rapidement
basée à cette époque-là 52 kg quand j'ai
vu madame quatre mois pour la première
fois aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui après 13
mois de protocole je suis à 83 kg ce
médicament ne fait pas de miracle
il aidera les passions qu'on ne peut
plus traiter actuelle moi je suis
franchement optimiste parce que les
performances que ne nous apportent les
molécules nouvelles nous permettent
d'envisager maintenant des scores
d'efficacité que auquel on ne pensait
même pas et encore de 3 ans je prends le
métro le bus comme tout le monde je
conduis le voyage et je n'ai pas fini de
voyager